Let's move on to sorting algorithms.
In a search algorithm you
have some kind of list, and
you're just checking out each element.
However, in a sorting algorithm
you're changing the order of elements
in an array.
Let's say you wanted to
sort these guys by height.
You have some decisions to make first.
Should I put the shortest element
on this end or on this end?
And what algorithm should I use to sort?
You could just compare every
element to every other element
until you have everything in order.
This is called the naive approach
since there is no real trick or
cool algorithm involved there.
The naive approach is normally the first
thing your mind skips to when you see
a new problem.
It makes you think I know I could do it
this way and everything's going to be
right, but there's probably
a smarter way to do this.
Sorting is kind of a weird topic.
You'll rarely be given a problem
that can't be solved with
one of the classic sorting
algorithms we go through here.
As far as interviews are concerned,
it's important to understand how sorting
algorithms work and
have their run times memorized so
you can answer complexity
problems really fast.
Lastly, you should make sure you've
considered whether your sorting
algorithm is in place or not.
An in place sorting algorithm
just rearranges the elements
in the data structure they're
already in without needing to copy
everything to a new data structure.
These algorithms have
low space complexity
because you don't need to
recreate the data structure.
Often you'll have that classic
tradeoff when you use less space or
use less time.
It doesn't really matter for
arrays with ten numbers, but
if you have millions or billions of
data points it makes a huge difference.
It'll never hurt to mention
that in an interview.
You can pick one way or the other,
but say why you're doing so.
The more reasons you can provide for
your choices, the smarter you seem.